ما نتعامل معه ليس في الحقيقة
هجرة أو مشكلة لاجئين ، إنه
محاولة واعية من قبل تركيا لاستخدام
المهاجرين واللاجئين كأدوات
جيوسياسية لتعزيز مصالحها الخاصة ،
فالناس الذين يحاولون العبور إلى اليونان
ليسوا أشخاصًا يأتون من سوريا  إنهم
لا يأتون من إيطاليا ،
بل سيعيشون في تركيا لفترة طويلة
من الوقت ، ويتحدث معظمهم
التركية بطلاقة ، لقد تلقوا
دعمًا كاملاً من الحكومة التركية فيما
يتعلق بتوفير الحكومة التركية
لهم النقل للوصول
إلى  المياه وبالطبع اليونان تفعل
ما يحق لأي دولة ذات سيادة أن
تفعله لحماية مياهها لأي معابر غير قانونية ،
وهذا ما كنا
نفعله وهذا ما سنواصل
فعله الآن ومن الواضح أننا رأينا
خلال الساعات الماضية زيادة التوتر  على
الحدود كانت محاولات
لإحراق السياج فعليًا حيث
قمنا بالمحاولات العديدة
لإلقاء الغازات المسيلة للدموع على قواتنا ، لذلك
أخشى أن هذا
إثبات مستمر ومنهجي للغاية  الموقع على الديوك الرومية
لديهم والتي لا علاقة لها
بمحنة هؤلاء الأشخاص الذين
يتم استغلالهم جيدًا في تركيا وهذه
أنت تعرف النتيجة هي أنه يبدو
أنك سترى حاليًا على
العالم التركي الضعيف  ربما يكون
السبب واضحًا ولكن هناك نتيجة
هي أنك الشخص
الذي يتلقى اللوم إلى حد ما ورد الفعل السيئ
عندما نرى نوع الصور التي
رأيناها الأسبوع الماضي حيث تكون قواتك
من نوع أو آخر  هم منخرطون في
إيقافهم ويخلق مشاهد قبيحة
وتحصل على اللوم جيدًا. لا أفهم
سبب وجوب إلقاء اللوم على
شيء قلناه علنًا
أننا سنفعل كل الحق في ريتشارد
لحماية حدودنا وهذا  هو بالضبط
ما نفعله نحن لسنا
من بدأ هذه الأزمة ، فنحن
لسنا من شجع الناس على العبور
إلى اليونان بشكل غير قانوني وبصراحة أنت
تعرف شيئًا ما هذه دولة
قبلت على مدى السنوات الماضية
مئات من هؤلاء  الآلاف من المهاجرين
واللاجئين الذين
فتحنا منازلنا فتحنا قلوبنا ، ومن غير
المقبول تمامًا كرئيس
وزراء لهذا البلد أن يُتهم بعدم
معاملة هؤلاء الأشخاص بشكل صحيح في
أوقات الحاجة الماسة.
الإنسانية
خلال هذه الأزمة ولكن ما
لسنا على استعداد للقيام به ولسنا
مستعدين للانخراط في عملية يستخدمها بلد آخر
بشكل منهجي وينتهك
هؤلاء الأشخاص لمحاولة إرسالهم
عبر الحدود الآن من حيث
المنهجية و  الأساليب التي
نستخدمها لم نستخدم أي نوع من
القوة المفرطة ونحن نتفاعل دائمًا ولا
نبدأ أبدًا
من حيث الرد على الاستفزازات التي
حدثت على الحدود